news daily from science mission
researchers used induced pluripotent
cells derived from autism patients to
understand brain development analysis
revealed in addition to upregulation of
genes involved in cell proliferation
neuronal differentiation and synaptic
assembly yes d derived cultures
exhibited an accelerated cell cycle and
overproduction of gabaergic inhibitory
neurons other show that overexpression
of the transcription factors Fox g1 is
responsible for the overproduction of
gabaergic neurons indicating a shift
towards governor dick neuronal fate
caused by Fox g1 may be a development of
precursor of a HD next jkt protein is
frequently activated in human cancers
and it is unknown whether system
inhibition of a single akt isoform could
regress cancer progression in cancers
that are not driven by akt activation
other show that timing lymphoma in p53
double- mice is regressed by akt1
deletion mechanistically jkt inhibition
in p53 timing lymphomas inhibits skip to
expression and induces fast L which is
the primary cause of cell death skip two
exerts resistant to cell death by
antagonizing the induction of farce l1
and reducing false expression the
results established a paradigm where by
systemic akt inhibition is sufficient to
regress tumors that are not driven by
akt activation for more news visitors
www science mission calm or science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching